for the first time after her re-election
sheikh hasina
the prime minister from bangladesh gave
an interview to an international
broadcaster and that was with deutsche
welle we talked about
her priorities about her fears and what
she wants to leave behind
once she will have left the office
[Music]
shy casino we are sitting here
underneath a painting
of your father who is the founder
of bangladesh muchiba raman he got
assassinated in august 1975
alongside with many of your family
members but you and your sister
you stayed in germany that that very day
has this shaped your relationship
to germany
well you see with german we have
always good relationship and 1975
as my you know my husband he was a
nuclear scientist
and he was working at cultural
university
so we just went there for holiday
for few days
that time i was a student of dhaka
university but
i i have two kids
and i took my sister with me i said
let's go there
we will be in a university area
you will get very good environment for
study
but it is unfortunate that within 15
days we heard that we have nobody
everybody was killed except these two
sister
yes i appreciate dharma government
immediately they
inform us if we want to stay back there
they are ready to accept it
so that way you can say yes
as because we were there so
chairman has very special you know
i mean friendly gesture to us so you are
now in office for the third term in a
row
and i hear rumors that you say this
might be your last term
i want to well it's a you know
consecutive thought term
and before that i was prime minister so
my fourth term
so i don't want to continue more
i i think that everybody should
take a break and then we can make
accommodation for
younger generation so you would say this
is probably your last
term do i understand you right when i
become prime minister first um then i
said okay
i don't want to continue i want to let
other to do but i couldn't stop because
well
actually we are struggling for
establishing democracy
and people's emancipation that's what i
would love to talk with you about prime
minister
so what would you like to accomplish
within these next five years
food security accommodation education
health care job opportunity these are
basic needs then definitely
every human being want a better life
then we have to ensure that
my father struggled his whole life for
this
people and the country he liberted the
country he wanted to build up this
country as a prosperous country but
he could do it so i feel that
this is my job but when you're talking
about establishing a democracy there's
more you want to establish it's like
freedom of speech is
human rights it's gender equality what
are you going to do in this regard
listen actually
what you see now in the country
it is not like this as because our
country
ruled by military dictator time and
again no
movement freedom of movement that was
the situation
we had only one television
no private television no private
radio how people can exercise their
freedom of space
so you say you're coming really actually
i bring a lot of change
1996 when i first time i became prime
minister
first thing i decided that i will open
up
everything to the private sector
one thing is to ensure freedom of speech
and show people's freedom of movement
and right
and our first priority was
to ensure food security
so can't it become self-sufficient in
food
then education
that is also very very important because
unless you educate people how can you
build up this country as a poverty free
country the prime minister would you
consider education one of your priority
priorities we took initiative that we
should ensure that
each and every one should get food
security and
side-by-side education we started
building
schools where there is no school and
also
encourage children to go to school we
started giving mother some
money or some facilities so that
she should send their children to the
school so that
we encourage them for education and for
health care we
started establishing community health
care center
what i feel that their
basic needs their food shelter education
then job opportunity that is also
and also security so it is their
human rights which role does freedom of
speech play for you
you just said that earlier on there were
only state ruled media this is changing
in your country
is it like um also a basic need that
people have the freedom of expression
oh yes of course they can and you
support that 100
100 also critical voices who who
criticize your
your style of leadership or your
decisions would you say this is part of
a democracy
listen if you work more then you will
hear more criticism but
you should ask my people whether they
are satisfied or not
what they think whether they
are getting all what they need
whether i can i mean provide
this we all remember i think the world
does as well
the situation of bloggers here in
bangladesh some years ago
many of them got murdered and killed on
the streets
well some incident happened but
immediately we took action
now you know the
[Music]
terrorism become a worldwide problem
and bangladesh also
face some extent but immediately we take
action
we declare zero tolerance to terrorism
and we we could have controlled that
yeah
how do you do that i mean zero tolerance
it sounds so easy to do
it's it's not that easy it is very
complicated it is true
but what i did
well in one hand i strengthened our law
enforcement agencies
and we train them and special
arrangement for them but what is more
effective
that is i just directly
i go to the people i call upon the
people
but um besides the awareness you needed
to build a coalition with
fundamentalist groups like hifasata
islam during the election
so do they want something out of that
now i told you that in this country
everybody has freedom of his peace so
they have also right to spell out what
they
want but what we have to do
of course we have to do because we
already passed the law
about the marriage age and they are also
we are in involving whole society
but you will fight for the rights yeah
we won't change the constitution
only law or taking action will not solve
the problem
but what i have done that our education
for girls is totally free up to 12 class
then we provide a stipend for them
free books we distribute for all student
and even our primary section
the girls enrollment is more than boys
and now parents now they want that
their children should be educated then
we create a job opportunity
for girls also because education is free
now parents also want that
his girl should you know
educate so they also think that their
girl should educate
so that then she will get a job
so marriage is not the only aim
opportunity for girls actually you have
to change the mindset
in the past parents used to think
why i should educate the girl because
one day she will get married she will go
to the
other another family but
now they don't think that now they think
that yes
i should educate my girl she will be
eligible to earn money
and well then she may get married
so that way we are bringing you know
change in the society gradually
now our child marriage has reduced
tremendously
so you you're fighting for that i hear
yes it doesn't matter if anybody
supported you during the election this
is something
you're not that's not negotiable for
your girls right of course
you have done done and it will continue
it will well
i don't want to fight with them or i
don't want to
spell up oh i will do it now
what is my job that is to keep peace
in this country a peaceful
atmosphere right so
well i told you the people have every
right to speak what they want to but
what is good for the country good for
the people good for the girls
boys are human being that is
my concern and of course we'll do that
i would like to come one more time back
to the uh elections
which just happened your ruling
coalition won 288 out of 300 seats
that's
96 that's nearly 100 what happened to
the opposition
actually you see when you contest
election what people want to see
who is the leader they couldn't present
that
actually their lack of politics is
mainly there that
they couldn't present any leadership
that who will run the country next
secularism is under threat in your
country
no no you wouldn't say so so you're not
afraid of
like really islamistic forces islamist
forces are there no doubt about it but
ah
if you can see the condition in this
country we have religion harmony
each every religion people they can
perform there
but people get killed on the streets
because of criticizing
or not living conform uh
some religious ideas it is not true they
got threatened
i mean we were talking about bloggers
earlier on i mean this there's a danger
in the streets isn't it
yes i told you that few incidents took
place but immediately we took
you know a step then it stopped
in our country we always
create atmosphere that each and every
religion
they can perform their religion faith
peacefully
honorably secularism doesn't mean that
no religion no we believe in religion
and everybody should have their right
and
we have religious harmony so you don't
feel any threat
islam is a religion for peace
now some only few people sometimes they
use
it but that is the wrong way they
shouldn't do it
prime minister thank you so very much
indeed
you